Yannick Nézet-Séguin, merci de
nous accorder cette entrevue.
- C'est un grand plaisir.
- Alors pourquoi, évidemment la
question, c'est tellement rare,
pourquoi cet engagement à vie
avec l'Orchestre métropolitain?
YANNICK NÉZET-SÉGUIN, directeur
artistique et chef principal
Orchestre métropolitain de Mtl
- Notre histoire est unique.
C'est rare qu'un orchestre fait
confiance à un chef à l'âge
de 25 ans pour ses destinées
artistiques. Alors déjà, ça,
c'était unique. Et c'est surtout
unique que 20 ans plus tard, on
s'aime encore plus qu'au début.
Et je pense que c'est une façon
pour moi comme pour l'orchestre
de rendre hommage à cette
confiance mutuelle et d'enlever
cette espèce de barrière
du temps qui est toujours là
parce qu'on se demande
tout le temps...
- Comme une épée de Damoclès
un petit peu.
- Oui, c'est ça, qui dit :
"Ah! oui, mais Yannick, ça va
bien, mais un jour, il va s'en
aller." Ou moi je me dis :
Un moment donné, ils vont
peut-être être tannés, ils vont
vouloir avoir quelqu'un d'autre.
♪ ♪ ♪
Puis au lieu, mais on se dit :
non, on s'aime, on fait de la
grande musique ensemble, nos
projets sont beaux, alors on se
donne encore plus de liberté
pour l'avenir en unisson nous
dessinait comme ça.
- Qu'est-ce que ça change au
fond sur le plan musical pour
l'orchestre, sur le plan
artistique?
- Ça peut changer artistiquement
parce que tout le monde sait à
quoi s'en tenir, il n'y a plus
une question de : Ah! si je fais
ceci, peut-être que Yannick nous
aimera plus bientôt. Moi, il y a
des musiciens qui me disaient ça
il y a quelques années : Ah!
toi, maintenant, tu diriges au
MET, tu diriges Philadelphie,
ah! tu nous aimeras plus, tu
nous trouveras plus bon. Et moi,
j'avais beau leur dire à chaque
fois : non, c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe, je vous trouve
merveilleux et puis je vois...
plus je comprends l'unicité
aussi du son de l'orchestre
métropolitain. Donc c'est une
façon vraiment de se donner
cette liberté, c'est-à-dire de
grandir ensemble encore plus.
- Vous parlez d'unicité, parce
que c'est vrai, vous êtes
maintenant au MET, vous êtes à
Philadelphie, vous êtes une
superstar. Ou est-ce que se
situe l'OM pour vous dans ce
palmarès là?
- C'est un orchestre qui est
jeune, parce que bon, on fête
les 40 ans l'année prochaine de
l'orchestre. C'est très jeune
par rapport à d'autres
institutions, Philadelphie ça
fait presque 120 ans, le MET
aussi, donc c'est sûr qu'on
parle pas de la même chose au
niveau de la notoriété
historique. Mais au niveau du
son, ce que ça donne, c'est un
orchestre qui a été fondé dès
les années 80 avec cette chose
visionnaire qui était incorporée
l'éducation, le fait d'aller
vers les gens, le fait d'avoir
des valeurs de proximité,
d'accessibilité, tout en gardant
le cap sur l'excellence en
musique. Alors ça, c'était
révolutionnaire dans les années
80, parce qu'en général, les
orchestres se tenaient loin de
soi. L'éducation, c'était pour
d'autres et quand on jouait dans
un orchestre, il fallait qu'on
soit déjà... les gens qui
venaient nous entendre devaient
déjà tout connaître. Alors que
nous...
- un public averti.
- Voilà. Mais aujourd'hui, tout
le monde parle de cette
démocratisation. Mais
l'orchestre métropolitain a
finalement beaucoup de longueur
d'avance parce que c'était dans
sa mission et je pense que ça
teinte le son et l'attitude
musicale des musiciens.
- Ah oui?
- Les musiciens se donnent à 200
%, qu'on joue dans un sous-sol
dans un arrondissement de
Montréal, qu'on joue dans une
église, qu'on joue dans une
acoustique très sec ou qu'on
joue en Europe ou au Carnegie
Hall, comme ce sera le cas
bientôt en novembre, ou conjoint
notre belle maison symphonique.
- Et donc cette décision, elle a
été prise en Europe en fait,
après votre grande tournée
européenne.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il y a rien qui me préparait
et qui nous préparait à ce
succès fantastique dans les plus
grandes salles du monde avec un
public qui en a vu passer
beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup et
qui disait des choses aussi
dithyrambiques que : ah!
maintenant, orchestre
métropolitain, c'est le nouveau
jalon par lequel on va juger les
autres orchestres.
♪ ♪ ♪
Je me suis dit : bien,
l'orchestre me donne tellement
tout et encore plus que ce que
j'aurais souhaité. J'ai envie de
continuer avec eux toute ma vie.
- Est-ce que ça va aider
l'orchestre pour le financement
public, pour la place de
l'Orchestre métropolitain à
Montréal? On sait que vous avez
eu tellement de difficultés,
et vous en avez encore, pour
répéter ou pour avoir accès
à la Maison symphonique.
Qu'est-ce que ça change
à ce niveau-là ou est-ce que
ça change quelque chose?
- C'est une décision qui a
des répercussions stratégiques.
Alors oui, nos partenaires,
qu'ils soient gouvernementaux
ou qu'ils soient aussi du monde
des affaires, souvent venaient
avec la question : c'est bien
beau l'histoire avec Yannick,
mais Yannick un jour va quitter.
Et il y avait cette incertitude
qui entravait parfois certaines
personnes qui avaient envie
d'investir plus de ressources
dans l'Orchestre métropolitain.
Alors c'est sûr que ça va
changer. Ça va donner aussi,
je pense, juste une plus grande
reconnaissance lorsqu'on est
à la table et qu'on peut parler
de comment on peut partager le
temps à la Maison symphonique.
C'est notre souhait.
Il y a des discussions
là-dessus.
- Vous avez déjà dit : on se
sent un peu comme des touristes.
C'est quand même incroyable.
- Oui. C'est quand même
incroyable. Mais en fait,
ce qu'il faut comprendre,
c'est qu'avec le niveau qu'on a
atteint, c'est un peu comme
un athlète olympique, s'ils
n'ont pas les ressources ou
les endroits pour s'entraîner,
c'est sûr qu'ils ne vont pas
gagner aux Olympiques. Ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on comprend.
Donc répéter dans des conditions
acoustiques acceptables,
c'est intimement lié au résultat
musical qu'on veut obtenir.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et c'est pour ça que c'est
important que nous aussi
on y soit. Mais ce que je trouve
beau dans ce message, c'est
qu'on ressent beaucoup d'amour
des Montréalais et ce que
je trouve unique de Montréal
plus je voyage à l'extérieur,
à l'étranger, c'est que c'est
pas une ville comme les autres
culturellement. On le dit depuis
des années, mais c'est une ville
qui a une richesse culturelle,
une variété de l'offre
une richesse de l'offre
culturelle.
- Les festivals...
- Tellement de festivals.
Et personne se pose la question
s'il devrait y avoir que le TNM.
Mais non, on a le Rideau Vert
puis on a le Centaur, puis
on a Duceppe et j'en passe,
le Quat'sous et tout ça.
Donc c'est sûr qu'il y a...
- Pourquoi pas deux grands
orchestres?
- Deux grands orchestres
internationaux, mais qui sont
aussi pour la communauté.
Et on a notre personnalité,
notre histoire différente et on
cohabite et on voit maintenant
qu'il y a la place pour ça.
Et c'est ce qui me rend très
fier dans cette annonce.
- Vous en voulez un peu plus,
dites-le.
- On veut juste notre juste
place.
- Est-ce que ça veut dire que ça
met fin complètement la
possibilité que vous fassiez le
saut à l'Orchestre symphonique?
Parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui se sont dit quand Kent
Nagano a annoncé qu'il patait,
que ce serait pour vous en fait.
- En fait, ma famille, c'est
l'Orchestre métropolitain.
On a une histoire qui est assez
unique dans le monde et qui a
fait en sorte qu'on s'est
trouvés et on s'est gardés.
Et je respecte beaucoup
l'Orchestre symphonique de
Montréal et je leur souhaite
de trouver la meilleure personne
pour être à leur tête.
Mais moi mon histoire ici est
avec l'Orchestre métropolitain.
Et effectivement, c'est une
façon entre autres cette annonce
de marquer que ma place
à Montréal, c'est l'Orchestre
métropolitain.
- Merci beaucoup